lots of 50s out there feels good a  little cool might need some long sleeves  if you're going to be out for a while so  far the winds are not kicking up yet but  man are they going to come to life as we  get through your monday mostly sunny  skies through the morning hours we'll  get back to some 60s and you'll start to  feel those southwest breezes through the  morning and they'll be pretty bumpy by  noontime by then a high wind warning and  some wind advisories will already be in  effect for southern nevada we'll look  for but low 70s for noon hour and start  to see some clouds too advancing towards  our area partly cloudy skies later this  afternoon and downright rough winds 45  maybe 55 mile an hour winds headed for  your evening commute and possibly some  showers too around the valley with snow  expected in the mountains this winter  storm is going to change things up  especially shaking things up but